yes
I could wear the prosthesis at this
level it's as if I had a
right hand which is at the base was
only a sculpture and which became
something much more
interesting
my name is jc sheitan xvi  in lyon and i
've been a tattoo artist for about
eight years
i lost my arm when i was
10 so 22 years ago the fact that
i have one arm less brings me look at the difference on the tattoo one day  I
asked a tattoo artist friend of mine who
showed me a machine from that
day on I let go of everything
I was doing a little bit to start learning to
tattoo solo we thought it
could be interesting
to have a dermograph mounted at the end
of a shell of prostheses my name is
gonzàlez i am an artist my
style is a bit biomechanical
biomechanical it is precisely a mix
that can be between the human and the
mechanization julien maes  met on
the conventions you got everything
basically o  u passing in front of his
stand like many people I was
just amazed by his work and
saw him a little bit of the new work I
had done and I think that's
when the idea came to him  came in
ten years I would like to have a
tattoo machine at the end of his protections
is it possible
I went to his house I got the
prosthesis back and then the senior project the
first objective was to be able
theater with this mechanical arm
but the aesthetics all the same for me was
a very important phase
this prosthesis will always be used
for color work of
style effects it will be essentially in
the abstract once the machine is
fixed on the arm  that it could
rotate 360 degrees so that it could be used prope
ly and I think he was pleas
ntly surprised finally I saw it a bit
like a kid who had a new
toy to work on and then
think  he quite quickly
also wanted a  e second
still a little more technical there
for the shot to really work a little more
for me the
always positive messenger well I find that j c
he lost only one arm he lost nothing
another that is to say that
he lost  incredible fishing he always
has ideas not possible yeah it's my
job of course but it's above all a
passion
I want you to do something I
do it and then and then we go